merci gauthier vous restez avec nous
bien sûr sur le terrain nous sommes donc
au cinquième jour de l'offensive russe
en ukraine l'ukraine qui affirme que
moscou a ralenti le rythme de
l'offensive alors que des pourparlers
ont commencé à la frontière entre
l'ukraine et la biélorussie dans la
région de tchernobyl est la délégation
ukrainienne devrait relayer la position
du président ukrainien et lenski qui
demande un cessez le feu immédiat et le
retrait des forces russes d'ukraine on
va retrouver tout de suite notre envoyé
spécial à kiev clovis casali bonjour
clovis alors que peut-on attendre de ses
proches par l'aiea à la frontière entre
l'ukraine et la biélorussie
difficile à dire le président ukrainien
zelensky fonde peu d'espoir pense que
ces pourparlers de paix ne seront pas
fructueux mais il doit à donner sa
chance il veut absolument la paix donc
il s'y rend par le biais bien sûr deux
ministres lui n'y va pas pour ca
pourparlers de paix je peux vous dire
que ici la population est plutôt
sceptique il vient d'avoir des tirs de
missiles grad sur kharkiv alors
justement que pendant ces pourparlers de
paix ne devait plus y avoir de tir russe
ou de combat c'est dire que la
population ici est méfiante il y aurait
de nombreuses victimes notamment chez
civile à kharkiv donc les ukrainiens
participent à ces pourparlers de paix
mais sont extrêmement méfiant à kiev
clovis le couvre-feu a été levé pour la
journée les ukrainiens peuvent donc de
nouveau sortir dans la rue bien sûr au
rythme des sirènes qui retentissent
régulièrement que vous distille ses
ukrainien après ces quelques jours de
deux blocus total de couvre-feu total
oui c'est important de dire que les
sirènes retentissent très très
régulièrement encore il y à une heure et
toute la matinée plusieurs fois ici dans
le centre ville de kiev conduisant les
civils à se rendre dans les abris anti
bombes de peur que les raids aériens
russes frappe certains immeubles
notamment à résidentielle alors oui le
couvre-feu ce très long couvre feu a
pris fin ce matin
et les russes les ukrainiens peuvent à
nouveau se rendre dans les rues mais il
ya assez peu de gens quelques personnes
et les gens en tout cas vont faire les
achats de première nécessité ils vont
dans des petites boutiques où ils vont
par exemple dans des pharmacies où on
sent on s'est rendu tout à l'heure avec
le reste de l'équipe on a parlé avec les
gens on a rencontré une dame d'ailleurs
qui qui était besoin absolument de
médicaments pour son mari qui ces
derniers jours a fait une crise
cardiaque
et aussi on a parlé avec des jeunes qui
venaient chercher des médicaments pour
eux pour leurs familles et qui nous
racontait qu ils sont extrêmement
mobilisés ils essayent aussi d'acheter
des produits de première nécessité pour
les envoyer aux soldats qu'ils
connaissent et qu'ils sont en train de
combattre ici à kiev ou plus loin
notamment un jeune homme qui a acheté
des chaussettes des choses très basiques
mais dont les soldats et les hommes qui
ont pris les armes ont absolument besoin
quand on leur parle des pourparlers de
paix quand on leur parle de la situation
actuelle ils nous disent qu'ils n'ont
rien contre les russes mais qu'il
déteste vladimir poutine que c'est un
homme cruel et donc ils n'ont aucune
confiance en lui ils souhaitent un
cessez le feu il espère que la guerre va
s'arrêter et pour revenir sur ces
pourparlers de paix et bien les
autorités ukrainiennes réclame un
cessez-le-feu mais aussi le départ de
toutes les troupes russes qui ont envahi
le pays merci beaucoup clovis casali en
direct de kiev la capitale